ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast we are back everybody's in the
studio today we're back we are starting
yeah this is this is this is you guys
aren't good at guests yet you got to
tell somebody well no no no no no
megan's turning that's got to tell us
yeah let's just hear on the podcast
guys everyone's back everyone's back in
person uh megan's here mary elizabeth
ellis is here
um
not a lot of hair though between the men
no
yeah we went short but but and i added a
little hair
and you've added some hair into your
hair to thicken it up sure yeah you
added hair to your hair it's a hell it's
a hollywood it's like some clips in
there yeah
like fake hair in my hair yeah yeah all
you have left is a rat tail so yeah
well i'm trying to keep up that's the
stress a little bit with me
but before we get into it we were going
to try something with uh mr glenn
howerton's head here yeah this is uh
this is uh so i wrapped the movie i
finished the movie um not last night but
the night before last
and um i no longer have to walk around
in the world like this if i choose not
to and i choose not to
right uh is there like a fire tuck thing
it's just a ring of baldness all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah a ring of baldness
is that what it is or the other way
around where it's just a little patch of
hair
[Laughter]
i don't know there's different versions
of him oh man but that's the best we'll
have the hair people build you a little
piece he has a skin yarmulke
all right i don't know what that is
a skin
what a rascal oh yeah
scallions all right but we're we're
gonna we're gonna take the rest of your
hair off cleveland cut that cut that cut
that we're gonna cut that hair
um well should we have our special guest
cut that hair that's no i don't want him
no she doesn't want to do it are you
sure too much pressure no i'm not a
woman that works for you who comes in
and cuts your hair when you want me no
but we get to tell you what to do now
yeah i wasn't sure if you were aware of
that yeah yeah
cut that cut that cut that look at my
right hand
yeah yeah yeah that's not a political
shout out no let's move on because we
need joy we need to enjoy
all right but i am excited about all the
ways that this hair could come off so
i'm down to pitch some well we have a
because we can can we can we yes but can
we mess with it we can grab it and start
yanking it no there's one way to do it
we can try a couple of different styles
before we go all the way off right
should i get baggies do you guys want to
save it or
to glue on the front yeah
we should get some kind of baggie to
cover glenn's shirt so it doesn't get
all the little hair particles down you
got that she's she's got a all right so
let's see
who would you like to do the clipping
what if we have two people going at once
i'm doing one thing on one side and
charlie's doing something we've only got
one razor yeah oh okay
what so what somebody's using the razor
outside and somebody's going to shave it
i've never shaved someone else's head
and i'm excited by the prospect i think
you should do it okay i think you should
do it and i i was okay with this
can i have uh however well you want one
wow
okay i was going to try and draw
something in there but i think that that
oh it's not going to try to that razors
yeah you might need something a little
more you want you want to do something
fun first what do you mean what do you
want to do or should we just uh there's
not a great palette there to
get this oh
move this coffee all the way it's very
power it's like a lightsaber
are we uh
okay you want to just get to it do we
need well i just want to make sure that
we're good are we good we just set a
camera up in the back too so we can see
what's going on back here it's very
exciting from my perspective psoriasis
in the background
that is that this is the area that has
the psoriasis this is the area that i
need you to be the gentlest
okay hold on a second too
we can make this multimedia i'll just
film it from the other side yeah let's
get a shot here i know
i don't know very well but i think you
go like this
and up yes that is correct and up i
don't go along the grain in the hair
no you go against it
you go against the grain
and i think you're supposed to push hard
yeah just push hard
don't push hard
here we go
full production tick tock this how does
that feel that's not too bad buddy not
to be left out
wow
oh boy how are you doing great job and
this is the gentle area i got to go
gentle here we've got a little dry skin
in the psoriasis can you see it
i'm still
charlie have you ever shaved somebody
else's head before this is the first
this is a first um first glenn
i'm i'm sensing an opportunity to really
release here to let go of some things
that you've been holding on to
right let's get spiritual
yeah people open up to their
hairdressers right yeah you should just
do that
we might have to do like a time lapse oh
rob
um oh that was fun
is it satisfying yeah i think so i think
it could be the guys like all right
you're shipping off on thursday
right
how is it is it uh is it close to the
length on top or is it not even close
because it's pretty it's really short on
top i mean i just shaved it
i think i'll adjust it after you get
that off i'll adjust it because i think
it goes a little bit closer wait so this
thing can go closer and we didn't do
that
got a good head shape glenn that's
awesome
i appreciate that i i um
yeah i've i've buzzed it pretty damn
close before i've never shaved it shaved
it but i've buzzed it like the way rob
has it even shorter than that and uh
yeah i was alright with it
this is this was a problem because i
shaved it
um
i had it done and it was a three and i
know that for a fact because
the woman that cut it said this is a
three
and you can
do it yourself if you want because it's
a three so i was in new york city and it
had grown back but it was at a weird
spot where i was like i can either let
it grow in or i can shave it again back
down to a three and i kind of like it
that look it feels good
so i went out to a store in new york
city and i bought a razor just like that
and i set it to three the three setting
and i shaved it and it went basically as
short as that what and then i called
around and it turns out it's not a
universal number no a three is not a
three no depending on the now how the
[ __ ] does that make any sense i'm so
sorry this here's a canadian three
yeah this is a new york city iii
let's just make it as confusing as
possible
why not just have an accepted
a standard
man yeah
yeah
i mean it looks pretty good is it pretty
close yeah oh man i want the eyebrows to
go so bad
get lower
like i want to shake my eyebrows off
yeah
and
the face no we're not going to do that
no no but i want i'm just saying yeah
something like what i want i understand
the want look at this guy i ain't taking
care of me it was a con air i'll throw i
threw it in the garden
[Laughter]
um i'm gonna just give myself a little
shake here shake it off
charlie you gotta lotion his head up now
i have so much hair in my hands
um we have a bathroom you could go wash
those hands glenn's in there looking at
his head you guys can talk about it in
the bathroom how are you
oh i'm so happy to be here as a guest i
feel um
like all the attention's on me
yeah completely worth my time and energy
and effort yeah it feels like you thank
you you made your way all the way to the
studio and all we've been talking about
is everybody else but you so i'm so glad
you're here thank you well it was really
fun
well now that they're gone let's get
into it
feel like a naked mole rat
yeah a little bit yeah yeah that's what
he's like yeah i feel like i've been
stripped of of something you know
dignity
yeah yeah yeah stripped of my dignity uh
stripped of sort of my iconic look you
know
do you think you is that like you're
letting the character go now that you've
shaved the hair off i think that i prob
that'll set in a little bit later but it
it is amazing how much how much that
really did affect
everything like how i felt how i walk
into a room how i feel when i walk into
a room i mean it is amazing
you know as an actor anytime you can get
have like a a tool like that to like
really assist in your transformation you
know what i mean not that i was doing
anything like
crazy transf transformative but uh you
know character has a very different
energy than mine so it it was it was
actually super helpful and just to be
able to tell people like i'm i'm working
so yeah
oh i wore a hat i wore a hat everywhere
there would be those moments you know
you know when you're wearing a hat like
you sometimes you take the hat off and
you just kind of like rub your head and
i'd be like oh [ __ ]
it wasn't even that i was embarrassed
about
being seen as like a bald guy i don't i
don't care about that i actually didn't
mind the way it looked i i in some ways
i kind of liked it the only thing i was
paranoid about was like i don't even
care if people were like oh glenn
howerton is
is bald
it's more oh glenn howerton's bald and
he wears a wig usually
normally he normally wears a hairpiece
because he's embarrassed that he's bald
that bugs me that's that is the thing
that bugs me actually be like if i just
think that you would think that that was
awesome
if some if there's like a few people out
there that start a reddit thread well it
is funny no that is funny that is funny
but uh but no i but does that make sense
like yeah i i wouldn't care if i was
just a bald dude i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
like you didn't want to see him in
authentic oh you don't want to see him
in office authentic or insecure or
insecure that i was hiding it yeah and
meanwhile it's an insecurity that's
making you feel
bad about you know right yeah it's an
insecurity that's like people are going
to think i'm insecure yeah that's a
crazy it's a loop it don't make no sense
man guys i'm insecure that we've invited
maryland with allison's podcasts and
haven't really talked
about her or to her at all or if we
could have a moment to talk or fair
enough yeah that's true that's true
welcome to the podcast let's do it yeah
let's get into it let's jump into it i
also want to say i'm a big fan of the
podcast
um and sometimes i'm a creep but usually
i'm a listener because usually i listen
in the car but sometimes i take it off
car mode and glance over which is
irresponsible and dangerous why i yell
at other people while they're driving in
their cars like i can't buy your phone
down yeah why are you
yeah and you're doing it you then heard
last week that you got credit for uh rob
dancing with elbows in your face during
the dance marathon episode
if i listened to last week yeah yeah
why don't you tell why don't you tell
mary elizabeth what you told us that i
remember you what you you were the one
that i was just trying different things
and you were like yes do that try to hit
me
don't actually hit me but it's it's it's
funny that i i'm not sure if i'm going
to be struck
you were laughing and i was like oh well
she's laughing then then then i'm just
going to keep doing it and you were
literally like bobbing and weaving as i
was doing this that was such a fun
episode so many just like a party
i love it when we have like a dirty
episode yeah like just everyone's there
most fun mary elizabeth we have been uh
together for 20 long years
um wonderful years and uh it's been well
documented some people think we met on
reno 9-1-1 but we were dating well
before that
but uh
do you remember you asking me to marry
you
[Laughter]
no my question was
what's your first memory of meeting
these two jokers
oh yeah that's a good question that is a
good question she doesn't remember
you see how we made it about us again
charlie just made it about us i love the
spirit of the question and what's your
favorite thing about each of us yeah
because we could flip that well but sure
i feel like did i i feel like i met you
and
um
bacchus
at that woman you were living at like a
woman's back house that's right that's
correct it was the very very first place
it was yes it was like just
i feel like charlie was like my buddies
from new york just got here that's right
i was like oh we could like get high and
drunk somewhere else today that's right
and you came over
at a different place yeah yeah we lived
in the guest house of uh of of an older
lady who's who's that lady don't know oh
yeah okay what's going on around the
internet okay
brave
and the drive across the country we
didn't know if it was going to be there
or not we just drove there and it turned
out we rang the doorbell and she was
like welcome here you had 50 bucks in
your pocket and yeah
that was a part of the she propositioned
you guys
of course
men and
she was i think she was 85 years old did
you guys try to drift her out of her
money tried to talk about her life no
grifting um we did just share that
little guest house but for a short
period of time i think it was like three
or four months
and in that period of time so that was
before that was definitely before uh we
met then because uh i think that i
didn't even i don't think you and i even
started hanging out together until you
had moved into that
apartment i feel like i also
my earliest memory of you places you and
your apartment
that you lived at that you ended up
moving into
i moved in next door i lived i've lived
just to be clear and i don't know if
we've made this clear in the podcast
i've lived either with he's a parasite
that is well established he's a parasite
yeah that is well established well yeah
it's my wagon when you lived with us it
was like having a teenage son
[Laughter]
you'd play video games and i'd watch you
yeah
[Music]
drink coffee there was a zombie game i
think president even resident evil yeah
yeah on the same dreamcast
after that that's yeah yeah i was like
oh i just really missed that yeah
i wanted to birth someone who would make
me um dinner on the george foreman
tater tots
man i i have nothing but good memories
of that but of course i was the parasite
in this situation i do remember the
conversation when charlie
said hey man and i could tell by that
it's time to go but he did it he was
just you know they're the sweetest
people and he did it in the nicest of
ways and was like you know just
mary elizabeth and i are going to take
the next steps which is like
not living with another dude
by the way i've been that person
for years as well like the new york
charlie was on everybody's couch and
apartment hopping until i found the
place on orchard street and then uh
you know even until i got the ifc money
i just i was i was like
you know living kind of like
in one place till it ran out or people
got sick of me and then mary elizabeth
when we first started dating i came out
and lived with you in silver lake and
tell your roommates kick me out i've
been kicked out of the best houses and
apartments all over the city by the best
people but you know you were never
kicked out for bad behavior
same with me it was just like overstayed
you're welcome
yeah you sucked us dry and then it was
time to go it's time to go um i paid
rent
yeah right yeah i paid yes i paid rent
it was nominal it didn't mean anything
to you i just took one of your checks
and just took it to the bank
so he did do the job of just running
charlie's money for him yeah yeah yeah
um and then mary elizabeth at some point
we started making uh love love
speech sweet we started making it's
always sunny and we asked you to play a
part yeah you were still living in that
silver lake house right when we shot the
first
we shot the part of the
not pilot but like
pre-pilot pilot at my house where i
lived with artemis bub danny
we also shot stuff at the olive outside
the olive garden and burbank well that
was that was so that was a different
thing yeah that was when we were doing
the um
have we talked about the first thing
that we shot on this podcast before we
shot the always sunny the hailey joel
osmond we'll talk we'll talk about it i
still have all of that yeah you've got
all the the tapes all of those dv tapes
so which we can start uploading we own
all of it we can put it into the podcast
and people can see this we should have
someone edit it together yeah so we were
shooting a mockumentary
about
haley joel on a grown up haley joel
osmena living with grown-up frankie
muniz yeah and they were both broke and
one of you had been in prison and had
like a teardrop tattoo even though you
hadn't actually killed somebody oh
really and i
and i played your acting teacher you
were there
who did you play in that i think i was
just a waitress at the olive garden yeah
oh my god that's right but i also was
the waitress that they all were
a waitress you were a waitress at the
olive garden in burbank and you played a
waitress at the olive garden who haley
has a crush on no has like a full-on
relationship with maybe that's okay a
backdrop honestly yeah we might have
taken that yeah
character
and been like hey do a version of that
character for
this play play a waitress in this thing
too and then play a waitress for the
rest of your life
scream waitress at you for the rest of
your life yeah do you know any other
types of women other than waitresses or
is that just what you're doing birds
they're airplane waitresses what are
they called
stewardesses
flight attendants
there's
within the last few years that's so
funny i didn't remember that you had
played a waitress at the olive garden in
our first thing and then you were the
waitress in the coffee shop so let's
just reveal the waitress's name right
now is
just helping my guests
do you guys remember what it is yeah i i
remember from from from the original
home so in the original and then we can
you know we should do we should say it
and then we can bleep it out
and i do remember what i know somebody's
going to mouth no you put you put a a
black thing over the face i reserve the
right to change it if we decide sure of
course and by the way we didn't actually
name her that we just we named her that
and then took it away and decided that's
not what her name should be well no it's
not but it is an homage to where we were
at the time it's not that we decided
that that's not what her name was uh
okay i'll just i'll say it wait should
we all say it on the count of three one
two three
yeah
nice but um if we did reveal that in the
episode the audience would be like huh
like yeah
it's not baked into the show so
no but everybody always wants to know
who what the waitress's name is and it's
so much funnier of course that you don't
know and i remember a similar thing
happening in the writers room we
realized we needed to name mac
season whatever it was and
i think i just said oh
let's just make him jimmy mc jimmy
mcdonald and then i remember you coming
into the writers room and being like
what's his name jimmy mcdonald and i was
like yeah we just got to come up with
the name and you're like yeah but we've
done it for so long we haven't revealed
it it should be a big reveal and i was
like i don't know i just just keep it
simple
and then we started pitching on it and
you were like no it's it's definitely
ronald that's because my baseball
coach's name was ronald mcdonald yeah
which is great you knew right now we
would need something
equally as profound as that for the
waitress otherwise if we just called her
no one would it just wouldn't have any
resonance
so guys what can't megan afford this
week well this week they're trying to
raise her rent and she spent all of her
money on the tesla of course so if she
can't scrape together the difference
she'll be forced to live in it can you
live in a tesla well let's make sure meg
doesn't find out with the help of our
friends at athletic greens athletic
greens makes one of our favorite green
powders on the market ag-1 i use it
because it contains less than a gram of
sugar this contains no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial anything and it
fits any diet that i may be on tasty
makes you feel good stimulates and also
weirdly helps you sleep at night it's
got 75 high quality vitamins minerals
whole food source superfoods probiotics
and adaptogens it's also good for muscle
recovery yes so to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free one
year supply of immune supporting vitamin
d and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit
athleticgreens.com
sunny again that's
athleticgreens.com to take ownership
over your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance
[Music]
if you got hair and you got bush you
better start using the following
products from manscaped whether you're
looking to go bald like an eagle or just
in need of a safe trim manscaped is
dedicated to helping you level up your
full body grooming game i personally
recommend the lawnmower 4.0 package it's
an electric trimmer designed to reduce
grooming accidents and shave hair on
loose skin thanks to a ceramic blade and
advanced skin safe technology when you
trim the hedges the tree stands taller
that means
your dick looks bigger yeah what are you
going to tell me next you're going to
say that they've got some sort of a nut
sack freshener and aftershave coolant is
that uh that's exactly what we're going
to tell you next instantly add some pep
in your step with the crop preserver
ball deodorant and the crop reviver
spray on testy toner that's a lot of
goodies for the boys as they say the
full monty they have a bunch of other
products on their website too so go
check them out get 20 percent plus free
shipping with our code
sunny that's
s-u-n-n-y
manscape.com again that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com and use
our code sunny yeah don't be a fool and
purchase manscaped's
ultimate bushwhacking tools
[Music]
should we go to a clip yeah let's do it
let's watch some clips
but i got to say when i was looking at
these i love that you go through quite a
hairstyle transformation over the course
of this show
always good but interesting every time
it sort of reminds me of uh mariska
hargitay and uh law order svu you can
kind of like demarcate the seasons with
like her hairstyle
what do you want charlie well maybe now
that you know that i'm not racist you
and i could maybe go on a little dude n
o
how many times do i have to say it to
you one time is fine well apparently one
time
well one time per time that i asked you
hey
what's going on up here oh not too much
charlie's using you to prove that he's
not racist and then he asked me out on a
date
wow that's from the first episode yeah
yeah
just problematic right out the gate
i mean sorry just not [ __ ] around
just pro i said problematic right out
the gate
that's good that's the point of the show
right you play you play the [ __ ] you
play this we all play that totally let
me ask you did you have a little cold i
feel like it was like i'm gonna start
talking like that again
is it inside my nose a little bit
yeah
dude
that
was a coffee shop where we shot the
original
movie pilot
which that scene i think not the whole
movie scene but the um
when we first got a budget from fx that
scene is in the episode
where i'm i have the like red sweater
and i'm watching you it's from charlie's
cancer
that's exciting
i'm just not realizing i was talking out
loud or not thinking no there was no no
what you're saying is there there was
footage because the original pilot that
we shot was charlie has cancer it was
not um the gang is racist and so there
is footage from the original fx pilot
that we shot that we then ended up
reshooting a bunch of but there's stuff
from the original 2004 one that we shot
in uh charlie has cancer yes that's what
you're talking about so that would be
the first scene that we shot for the
show not necessarily that one but the um
the first coffee it was the first one
that aired with
that was the person that aired with uh
with the waitress character and did we
go on a date in this one is that the one
that we then shot the date in philly no
like montage date no that was in charlie
has cancer oh okay so that was the that
it's it i get it mixed up too that was
that was the original pilot yeah we used
to shoot in philly and we used to drink
a lot of yingling a lot of so much of
all of the things yeah and there was a
lot of there was a beluga remember there
was a beluga in the uh
in the skoogle there was a beluga in the
skugal a balloon
pilot there was a beluga whale shooting
in this google and just the philly
accent
i believe you gotta call it
[Applause]
yeah and i never heard that accident and
i just couldn't stop watching the news i
was so excited how did a [ __ ] blue
whale get in the skeukle river swam uh
probably released from someone's evil
lair
you know what i mean like this beluga's
not doing what we needed to do and dump
it in the school club
why don't you get a shark you know
you can't do [ __ ] with them i don't know
from sharks and whales
lumpy muscles
all right
what do you want charlie i like your
bracelet
great that's one of those uh lance
armstrong
race for the cure
live strong
kind of things yeah
this is the scene this is one of the
first things that we shot you must be a
very compassionate person
did you want to straight up i'm not
admitting it i'm not
i'm not all right hey dennis charlie has
cancer
[Laughter]
really
nope
are you okay
just so long into the eyes
but also like looking like looking at
all of it
yeah and then back up this is so much
better to me as an introduction to your
character because it's not you're not
just playing the foil to charlie's like
craziness yeah you're actually a real
piece you're a piece of [ __ ] too yeah
because if you're attractive oh yeah oh
yeah the waitress if she loves because
in the other episode it's she sort of
seems like the rational one and charlie
seems like the [ __ ]
in this if you're attracted to dennis
there's something very wrong with you
you're a real real piece of [ __ ] no he
was the golden god we went to high
school together you know just chasing
that golden god tale yeah we had that
all written out in the canon we knew
exactly oh we had it all planned out it
was all planned out uh they went heavy
on the eye makeup and that yeah well we
were doing like a 90s like
um
i don't know janine groffalo like she's
like oh like yeah yeah yeah like cranky
like yeah kind of thing right i was
thinking i'm thinking more shirley
maclean well that's the 60s you get that
shirley maclean yeah that's your look
too and then i missed the break for sure
you know yeah i'm i'm getting my hair
done tomorrow you guys make it brown
make it brown make it brown make it
brown make it brown good job
you have to do it because men told you
to do it now yeah yeah that's the rules
i will i'll [ __ ] take it to the
supreme court yeah
done and done and then you'll get your
own you're sure and then you'll have
brown hair then you'll have brown hair
yeah that's right speaking of crazy
women i do have to say that it is always
a delight to see where my character is
going at the beginning of every season
i'm like okay so what are we doing we
doing sober we doing on the wagon we do
an off the wagon right
and i appreciate that yeah we untethered
you more as the seasons went on with the
yeah yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] in a purse
at some point
i will say when we go brown with your
hair i don't think so when mayor
elizabeth and i go like to the airport
or out to a restaurant go brown with my
hair
when we go around with your hair for the
show when we
go brown with your hair
um like when we're pregnant
the one who gets recognized when we walk
around is you but that's also because i
always make eye contact with everyone
yeah yeah because
you're wearing your ray bands and and
you've got a hat on you're keeping your
head down yeah yeah which i would have
done before fame as well you know what i
mean like i
when we first started dating in new york
it would be walking by
[Laughter]
are you on
drugs
can i have some trying to get us mugged
i do remember you being like you're
you're gonna get stabbed this is new
york city what are you doing
i'm being nice yeah but it's suspicious
when we go brown with your hair when the
supreme court decides that uh your hair
must be brown yeah um
i don't think you'll get
stopped as much
let's see we'll see okay next next
anymore
bam
what's that
two hundred dollars
why
well dennis was thinking that that might
help convince you to sleep with our
friend charlie gross
250.
oh wow yeah yeah that's great
yeah that's fun you're just a piece of
[ __ ] yeah i do remember this is the
first episode that i remember watching
like that that as iconic for me for the
waitress because for exactly that reason
because because i was like oh good she
gets to do yeah like bad stuff she's
delicious
yeah she's just this good but i also
like he's rejecting charlie
which i think is everybody's favorite
part yeah the most fun it's everyone's
favorite part yeah that's fine and it is
also crazy that we're all in our own
clothes all the time oh yeah
every single yeah in the beginning but
not that hat i don't think that was your
hat i think somehow we're like
well we wanted you to wear philly's hat
i don't remember why that's what it was
you can't she couldn't show the logo
yeah so he turned around backwards yeah
but what was the why why did we want to
have you in a i don't know philly's hat
was there like maybe
i don't know real philly wait wait wait
don't don't go i want to go inside
no i'm not gonna ask you inside dennis
why not
because
i really
like you wow yeah i mean
i really like you too
then let's just take it slow okay now
this is phil this is the city of
philadelphia this scene is great it's
todd biermann's this is todd biermann's
house yep crazy oh well wait
i love
you
look at your face look at your face oh
just lit i just want a page
i like that you felt bad about saying it
at least no i didn't no no i just was
trying to get the word out
i was just trying to get the words i was
like how do i get these words out and
come across as sincere
that's that that's what it was i didn't
feel bad about it at all no no no no not
at all i just i was i was worried that
that if i didn't commit enough to it
that it wouldn't get away i was also
checking in with you am i getting away
with this
yeah
the answer was a resounding yes
i kind of don't know what to say i don't
want you to say anything
you're so
so close you
i'm ready to talk
kind of pretty close there pal i almost
sealed the deal
just meet me at paddy's and we'll work
it all out schmidt
hello
the phone mess well let's go no
i'm gonna go
yeah i'm gonna go now we should take it
slow you were right why would i not want
to go home
it's crazy it makes no sense well you
have an agenda you have that i know but
she's because she likes you and you hate
yourself i can have it both ways
but you realize that it would be
psychology there would be a lot of uh
trouble to deal with with charlie you're
trying to get a thing from charlie you
don't care about that as much as you
care about getting the thing which is
not doing the charlie work i feel like i
could yeah all right
i had sex
with your dad
i had sex with your father because just
like you i like my sex old and ugly and
with fake hair on their heads that falls
off when you're having sex with them it
just falls off because that's what you
do dennis reynolds you like to have sex
with old people
that's the end of the episode right
so tell us about those that was the
first scene you ever shot with danny
yeah that scene right there yeah
yeah
and um and we asked you to improvise a
lot of that right because not a lot of
that was written i think i think we put
you in sort of a bad position go off
just kind of just go off which which is
it is
it's awkward but i'm thank god i'm a
genius
yeah there was also did we come in
through a door i feel like we were just
behind like a black curtain
there was no like psych or whatever
you know like so it was almost like no
money yeah yeah because you see a weird
piece of a wall that doesn't exist out
there i really feel like we were behind
like a stage curtain or something and i
had only i feel like i hadn't met danny
all that many times before we started
shooting season two right probably yeah
so i feel like i was like hey how's it
going you know when he's like
to me and i'm like what is it he doesn't
care he's being in character yeah being
a character yeah oh he was but i was
like oh
but it helped yeah
right i'm disconcerted i don't know
what's going on right now you're
uncomfortable danny has a thing where
right before the camera rolls he usually
yeah like an improv a line or two in
make some sounds yeah make like if he's
being lascivious he like gets into that
or if he's being angry he might
be moody about something but like yeah
he goes he goes he goes that way
sometimes like
it's not like a method thing but it's
just like a little like just a little
warm-up so you don't just go in ice cold
yeah but you don't know him as you said
that no but that was that was also
helpful for you because you really
genuinely look
disturbed
yeah yeah
yeah so that
that's great so but but other than that
had you talked to him were you guys i
don't know i don't remember how much we
had hung out with him before not much no
i mean we didn't really know that
well i mean we were still on the clock
at this point oh yeah this early in the
shooting of season two we had what 15
days to shoot him out entirely and so we
knew we had to just churn through it as
quickly as we could and then he gave us
an extra two weeks or so five or
something like that but yeah i think at
this point we weren't hanging out we
would like get the guy and get the guy
out maybe gone to the upfronts or was
that later when he told the box of teeth
story that one box of uh teeth and
watches story was told to us at a lunch
before we even but then he told it at
the tca's i think yeah like up front
yeah television television critics
christ almighty yeah or
whatever we did go to one of those
i remember ice cube being there because
he he had this show black and white or
whatever it was did he oh the the oh the
documentary yeah effects there yeah and
i was before you know i worked with him
so i was like wow that's ice cube but
like um and then danny gets up and and
of course danny and ice cube talk to
each other in that way that celebrities
do you know or they're like hey you're
famous you're famous let's do a quick
like
but we weren't famous right so we were
just like oh the thing the famous the
spiders people are like
let them go you can just do that you can
just do that yeah the constellation i
don't know i still don't feel like i can
do that do you feel like you can do that
yes
yeah it depends
yeah it depends on who it is yeah it
depends on who it is but at this point i
do find that that uh even people uh
because you know it used to be
that nobody knew what the show was and
then there would be the occasional
people that had seen the show and liked
it and knew what it was and now there's
a lot of people that have seen it still
quite a few who haven't but they still
know who we are
you know what i mean at least they it's
been on for so long they couldn't get
away from it they couldn't avoid it they
tried they love mountain dew they love
it they're just massive
i got my mountain dew fans and there's
certainly a uh a cutoff with age right
like um
like still like 50 and over might know
the show
and i got assaulted in a bar
on sunday um being together by two
parents whose kids love the show and
we're like
so excited to take a photograph with us
and it was so overwhelming because that
doesn't happen in la normally that was
so this was in l.a yeah normally in la
people when they get that excited and
then you think it's about you are like
can you take my photo with brad pitt
who's standing behind you
yeah you're a person here to hold the
camera to take my photo with brad pitt
but it's got to be it's got to be even
more intense when you and artemis are
together
i think they i find it's always more
intense when i'm with one of the other
when i'm with these guys or one of these
guys or you know caitlyn or dan anybody
you know i talked to you guys when i was
in new york it was my birthday we went
out artemis took us to this irish bar
that was open till like three and three
or four in the morning or something like
that
we walk in it's like
you know covet's still happening we walk
in it's almost empty so exciting to be
in like a place that's almost empty in
new york you know and we're like oh we
have the run of the place there's just
three people there two women and a guy
and
the blonde woman's like kind of swaying
and then like she makes eye contact with
me
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
like not not that she recognized me but
just that she was like i need to talk to
her you know
you know
looking at you
i think they look through you they right
like i think that's a trick to do is
like you just like through somebody
and i feel like women to women drunk
often they need to tell you a secret but
into your mouth
i'm gonna tell you
and then you're like that's i don't hear
that place so if you put yourself it's
the best way to tell you is to get it
again if i put my sticker in your mouth
then you'll have my secret in your
then she was like wait wait
but am i in philadelphia now
you're still in new york city yeah yeah
but
yeah so yeah
that was amazing she was very confused
and wanted to know where danny was
speaking um like taking pictures of
celebrities i remember going to the boom
boom room with danny and we were all
there
in new york city like after we were
doing a press tour we and he was like
let's go daddy boom boom yeah i remember
that too what is the boom boom room
though what was that
is
somewhere off times square where we had
been doing it doesn't sound
no sounds like some kind of club and of
course like danny's getting swarmed and
uh
i remember some like club girl
be like take a picture of me and him
take a picture and she like you know
shoves her camera into my hand and then
she's talking to danny she's not really
paying attention so i just kind of walk
over to the other side of the bar and
just hang out like have a drink you know
and she's like freaking out some guy
stole her camera
and then i like i come back and i i go
she's like why don't you go i was like
how far back did you want me to take the
phone off
she said get out to me
give it back to me it was also it just
was a camera right like it was like yeah
yeah yeah fun but yeah that's amazing i
used to like the toy with people
that's funny
the drunker i got you know yeah it's
hard it's hard to go into an irish pub
these days it's uh it's just there's no
higher concentration of sunny fans uh
than than in an irish bar sure
the last time i think i was
god i mean one of the last times i was
even in one was with the whole cast and
we
just for fun we were like let's just see
what happens if we go out to an irish
bar
in new york city we were there for like
some upfront event or something like
that and it was a [ __ ] show
asking for it yeah just asking for it
but you know what speaking of danning
getting to know danny and fame and i
always feel like when people are like
how
if someone who's not an actor in the
industry sees people being super excited
about seeing me and wanting to take a
photo with me i and then they're like
how is that like what's that like
i feel like danny early on was really
great at teaching us
to be grateful for that because
those fans are the people who let us do
our jobs like having a fan is how you
get to keep working and it always so
so it's nice to go into it with that
like
i really appreciate it i still i still
really appreciate it because i i feel
like it's not because i'm famous uh it's
because they love the show
which feels good like that feels good
it's like if someone's excited to meet
me it's because they like my work it's
not because i'm famous yeah like that
because there isn't a tablet at the
grocery store right you know they
genuinely love the show but danny you
know what
because we always started to say that
like he was such a good example of how
to be gracious with the fans but he also
had this other side right where if
someone was like crossing it or if he
didn't want to deal with it he'd shut it
the [ __ ] down yeah and
i liked that too like it was a good
lesson of like hey be gracious to
everyone but also
have that on your back
have boundaries and protect yourselves
anyways lots of good danny lessons in
the beginning yeah yeah yeah and not so
much now
now we're teaching him yes
all right so we're here for our primal
kitchen sandwich making competition
where you guys are gonna make me a
sandwich using these amazing sauces and
mayo's from primal kitchen
and there are meats and cheeses and
everything i like everything out here
and uh i'm gonna step out because they
said they want me to judge this blind um
because they think that i have favorites
which i don't um but i'm gonna step away
and you guys make me whatever sandwich
you would like
and then uh and then i'll come back and
try them
now the question that we have to ask
ourselves is
what kind of sauce does meg like well we
you know you would know better than us i
got some of this primal kitchen uh just
regular mayo you know what i mean i got
some of that primal kitchen mayo as well
what i'm going for is variety something
a little dangerous here i want each bite
to be a little bit different half the
sandwich with this pesto mayo
and i might add a little bit of ranch
i wish i had a better
knife to cut this with but
primal kitchen doesn't make knives
i botched it all right i'd like to uh
call megan in before my get soggy i
really really really
want her to like my sandwich better so
do i
yeah i feel like the steaks are pretty
high here for me they look good one of
you has chosen to cut it the other two
told me to go for myself
i actually do love primal kitchen stuff
so i'm pretty excited to eat these
sandwiches yeah they're sauces
i'm gonna start with this one that's
closest to me i like it's got some
avocado
it looks like turkey i'm looking at
yours glenn and if i had to choose i
would choose i would choose yours to eat
i don't know it looks awfully creamy
what does that mean
it's two different sandwiches in one
sandwich oh this one's sort of falling
apart but she likes that side well
you're going in for a second bite of the
same size i gotta try the other side oh
this one side of
the of the side a side of the side
doesn't like the other side and then
this one yeah potato chips in there now
if that cuts down i was gonna say it
might cut the roof over that shoulder
for me it's between
this sandwich and this half of this
sandwich so i'm trying to decide whether
or not this other half of the sandwich
will deduct take another bite
another bite
tell me what's on them try this try this
bite i like how much you're touching it
that's nice well i made it
okay so what's in this
oh gosh
dude you sh this did he dock his score
i think glenn wins whoa
which one because
there's so much mayo on it and i really
like that
i took a risk with that i took a risk
that's a risky move i did a i did a
primal kitchen
just a regular mayo made with avocado
oil and then i used the uh the chipotle
just a little touch of the chipotle lime
i could taste that that was great thank
you all for making me uh
lunch
i'm probably gonna eat the rest of these
when we're done now i'm looking at
glenn's
it's clearly the winner it's very good
it's a it's a good looking sandwich
[Music]
oh my god charlie where did you get a
baby so you can just give me the baby
and stop screaming there was a time
tasty treats give me the number for
child services yes she's like
there is a there is
a moral barometer it just depends on who
who we need it's your needs and wants
yeah right so the whole thing is like if
you really need her on something she
draws the lines of
babies i think i get from that though
that she is genuinely concerned for the
for the well-being of that she should be
a man covered in filth that's right yes
has strapped this baby into its chest i
do also remember us questioning in that
that i was like so i just tell the guy
that works with me to get me the number
for child services
so i still am kind of a piece of [ __ ]
i'm like i'm not gonna do it find me the
number four
you're that kid manager
yeah yeah yeah right you're not gonna
flip through the phone book yourself all
right here's a scene with you and
caitlin dee
oh i love this honey hi this one's great
are you applying for a job here here
yeah what are you crazy
gross no i don't work here i'm working
here i'm working here so do you think
that you could get me a job
here yeah i thought you weren't applying
no that was a lie
okay
did you go to high school or oh
well i don't know that we goofed up we
just hadn't written yeah yeah no we
goofed up lately later so you made you
did that improv
and then later we established that you
sat next to her and that she didn't
remember
but we had forgotten the improv when we
wrote that
you shouldn't be drinking in a shoe
store what is the matter with you i told
you to pace yourself i have a
you should know how to drinking
your boots a little better i'll hold
your boobs a little bit
you and katelyn together is such a good
dynamic
it's always like i it's always like a
thing i have to like sage myself after
though and be like caitlyn does like me
wow you have a bad attitude when you're
drinking you have a bad attitude when
you're drinking you huge footed [ __ ]
really yeah
was fun for that too because we put
lipstick all around the bottle so it
just was making like bottle marks
what is it how do you do the because
your drunk acting is just phenomenal
it's phenomenal and i don't know
how do you i know is that it though are
you literally just drawing from like
what what you cause like i feel like
i don't know it's it's just i find drunk
acting to be extremely difficult and it
seems to come so naturally for you you
guys have all talked about this but i
feel like all of our drunk acting is
good but i remember
i remember being like in college then
being like when you're drunk you
are trying
very hard
right
to sound just to sound right just sound
drunk so you think about what you're
going to say a lot before you say it and
over and over
that's very good
pretty good i know i remember that trick
too but for some reason i don't feel
like it i do i can i can't just can't
pull it off as well as you can i don't
know i feel like your junk acting is
very good well thank you i appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
why does he think this will work
that lyric if you want to if you want to
marry
me please
just
[Music]
your face
said it
oh my god
that moment where you open up the
program in the middle of his song to be
like is this this one this is yeah yes
this one is not listed
yeah the song is not listening i thought
we had finished every one of those those
not to objectify you for a second but
can you pull that back up
you look great
it feels like very very rarely in our
television show do we do people look for
people look good yeah especially when
you stand up and uh you got a hand on
the head there you go find the light
yeah you're like got that sweet sweet
cleave going on
you know
this is when it's nice when you've been
on television since you were 25. so you
can be like oh remember that part
like how my parents were always like
don't just don't get naked and i really
wish i had you know all right that would
have been the time right that's what
you're saying yeah
still time there's still time
anyway let's get naked that's what i'm
saying you know you just don't want to
get to a point where it's brave
where it's considered oh right you know
what i mean when people talk about it
this is a big scene in the canon of the
show that we should talk about i'll play
this one next coming
which one is this hey come on
that's a different look i don't ever
remember your hair looking like that
yeah i see it you poke around the
preschools and the playgrounds and you
got that longing look in your eye wow
that's so creepy i don't know what
can you stop it for a second i have no
idea i've never seen her like this i
don't know what episode this is i don't
know what's about to happen oh really
this is not even that long ago this is
the episode where uh
he they actually
have sex i think
yeah but um do you not remember that
that happened in the show
no
now i'm remembering it yeah i barely
remember it and now i'm remembering it
we're about to watch he tells her that
okay yeah
life with charlie
and a baby
did you really think that this was gonna
work did you really think that well you
would just have me in here and you could
just
hurl insults at me and i've tried
everything for years with you and i just
at this point i just can't really play
this so why don't you just go find
somebody better
well
because there is no one better
oh that's so sweet
i love you
and that's how people should propose
that's a really funny concept though
like
pining after your character forever and
then finally reality of a relationship
that you
it's a true thing right people really
want to think super bad and then they
get it and they're like wait a second
what also just like looking at lying in
that bed made me so grossed out right
now yeah
yeah
yeah that's pretty gnarly
if you came to shoot me
at least let me finish my drink first
cat food and whiskey i'm not gonna shoot
you
what if i missed
[Music]
well
then you'd have to say you missed me
ugh maybe i did
man maybe i missed you too
i mean
can't fix your drink no thanks i'm sober
plus i saw you put cat food in it
also the voice that you're doing
like however you're doing that voice is
on it thank amazing
we were playing with when to keep it and
when to yeah yeah
yeah that's for the fun of the episode
yeah here it comes out all right because
you dropped it i saw you sleeping
so bad you're so close to me with that
[Laughter]
top to bottom i i i forgot about i
completely forgot about that episode
it's fantastic oh yeah you're writing in
that
oh my god so [ __ ] good all the
performances keith cullen's [ __ ]
direction yeah dude
you're acting in that is like you were
born to play something in that
truly truly true
i know it's so fun to write into a into
an episode that you get like a glamour
shot where we like specifically set up
for that one moment when he first sees
you and you look up and then he's just
describing how beautiful you are i was
like i loved writing that and then the
um sabrina the head of costumes was like
thank you for writing something that has
costumes in it so i'm not just
dressing them in the same corner of
course just basically dressing up in our
own gloves yeah okay well here's the bog
stuff that i also really love um from
this year so watch this waitress oh
my god what the hell are you doing out
here what are you doing out here with a
toiletry bag are you gonna brush your
teeth in a stream or something no
i was gonna
shave my legs ew
gross
judging from the box
she's sinking in a bog
just give me a big tug and i bet you
could get me out yeah yeah here here i
got you let me just stop my hand
[Laughter]
two times
two times this was not scripted no no
the cycle was your idea yeah
all you have to do is one thing yes
great what
say my name
is
valentine diana
dennis
dennis
oh no no you you got it a while back
it's just
i'm really enjoying watching you
struggle
you drunk [ __ ]
oh she went under i asked her to go
under for one day i was like you gotta
go under yeah
i can't believe
[Laughter]
you're doing it
[Music]
because she was physically dirty yeah
yeah yeah yeah she did you understand
what's happening
yeah very fantastic and that was just a
selection there's many it's just a taste
fantastic i i feel like i had so many
more questions to ask you but so will
you i i still have things i want to talk
to you about will you come back at some
point no this was it
okay i'll do whatever you tell me to do
yeah yeah yeah yeah don't ask that's the
thing don't ask she can come back with
brown hair and then i gotta come back
with my brown hair so i'm gonna bring it
here i've decided
yes we've decided the men have decided
that it'll be it should be brown for us
uh jokes aside
you know it's been a pleasure
doing obviously business uh we lived
together and have been together for many
years but
working together is always a joy every
time you're on set
it's a blast
and uh i hope we get to do more and more
and more of it yeah i mean you've been
such a huge part of this from the very
very very very beginning
which is something i at some point i
want you to come back and talk about
what that was like in the beginning like
your memories of what it was like in the
beginning but we'll save that for the
next one i'm so i'm so grateful for this
and always when people are like what's
it like to work with your husband what's
like to work on sunday and it really
does feel like um
like family it does
it's just fun and
easy and lovely and
we drive each other crazy sometimes and
i miss our family vacations to philly i
want us to start i know i missed that
too i i have a professional question for
you okay
how similar uh was working with paul
thomas anderson uh working with us is it
the same vibe exactly
is it the same level of genius that you
yeah and that puts out a movie every
four or five years we put out a mini
movie eight maybe eight movies every
year for the last twenty fifteen yeah
yeah yeah that's what i'll start saying
yes like i'll start saying um instead of
it's like being with family i'll say
it's like the paul thomas anderson of
television yeah yes yeah yeah that's
right you will like that they're the
ptas of tv pta tv i'm gonna i'm just
gonna do this
[Applause]
thanks mary elizabeth
thanks for having me